this season of travel dares finds us on
the road to reconnect with the us and
what makes it unique
on this episode i'm visiting a place
known as the country's oldest native
american artist cooperative
[Music]
last episode i got a clue for where i'd
end up on this episode use your fingers
to hand craft a piece of pre-colonial
history which led me to asheville a city
nestled in north carolina's famous great
smoky mountains but i'll actually be
traveling just outside the city to the
town of cherokee where i'll be visiting
the koala arts and crafts mutual so i'm
going to wrap up breakfast now and head
on over there thank you so much
[Music]
heading to the koala arts and crafts
mutual today i hear it's their 75th year
anniversary really excited
hi nice to meet you nice to meet you i'm
jenna i'm tonya welcome to koala arts
and crafts thank you for having me i'd
love to know a little more about why the
cooperative was founded and and when it
was founded the cooperative was founded
in 1946
by a cherokee artist and they wanted to
have a place that they could sell their
artwork year-round we have a lot of
different mediums of artwork at koala
arts and crafts we have traditional
cherokee baskets stone carvings wood
carvings we also have contemporary work
like beadwork drawings paintings prints
and even some textiles the koala arts
and crafts has over 250 artist members
currently a lot of the artwork is passed
down
through family members through the home
but also our school system has adopted
cherokee arts and crafts as a class so
most schools have a stem program our
school system we named it steam which
adds the a in there for the art so it's
science technology engineering the arts
and math i love that
so now we're gonna give you a taste of
some of the arts and crafts we do here
are you ready jenna oh yeah i'm so ready
hi hi what's your name i'm tara tara i'm
jenna it's hi it's very nice to meet you
nice to meet you i am dying to know
about pottery i'd love to know how you
got into it how long you've been doing
it i started when i was probably around
seventh grade and i stepped away from it
when i went to college and then when i
came back home
i picked it back up and i've been doing
it since 1999. it's a long time
i'm in good hands
yes so i hope so all right so you can
get your clay i already cut your ball
clay out and so you're just going to pat
it
shape it out
so you just get it in a flat disc and
you're just going to use your roller and
you're just going to flatten it out
and then you will take this this is your
base
and all we do is we're just going to lay
it around and you're just going to press
it down
form it to the bowl okay or the base
[Music]
so now that our clay has dried we're
going to add some coils to it okay yeah
you're gonna take
a ball of cake and all you can do is
you're gonna just start
squeezing it into like a snake
and all i do is i lay it on top
[Music]
of my pop at this stage i use my paddle
and all i'm doing is i'm gonna go around
and smack the clay with it
and suddenly if you notice as you're
smacking it's getting thinner the clay
is getting longer
and then once you get to where you want
to go once you get your decorations on
and you like the shape then i will let
it dry for about seven to ten days and
then you can put it in a kill there's
your pots thank you so much for teaching
me a limited amount of time but i you
know i feel like i absorbed
hopefully at least a little bit you
should be able to wake up go home and
make a pot now
[Music]
hey hi
i'm jenna i'm bill hi bill
jamaican
a turtle i'm carving a turtle at a soap
stall a turtle out of a soapstone i tell
kids my knife's magic because it'll cut
a rock
how long have you been doing this
off and on since 1986. 1986. yeah okay a
long time yep how'd you get started i
got sick back in the 80s and wasn't able
to work for a couple years
and
i can't do very well at waiting and
sitting and stuff like that so i started
doing something with my hands
how do you become a member
here at the cooperative you have to
show
the board that you can do the work
you have to present three to five pieces
of your work and then we will call you
in to demonstrate for us so that we'll
know you did the work and if the work is
the quality that we want here
then
you can become a member well now i'm
really nervous because i want you to
show me a few skills but i do not want
to be tested
okay
we can do we can work with it your
enthusiasm is contagious
choose your weapon
you've got knives i feel like this one
looks like i'll do the least damage on
myself
okay
i'll just start
trying to check it out first to cut that
stone
there's sometimes little hard spots in
it sometimes it's i'm just feeling hard
spots in general yeah
what makes koala special in your opinion
the fact that we are trying our best to
keep
a tradition alive these walls right here
around us
have
objects in them that were made some of
them many years ago and you go out there
and look at the shelves at the new work
and some of it's almost exactly the same
i wouldn't say it's exactly because
i can sit here and carve
a hundreds of these turtles and you
could probably name them because i doubt
if i could carve two exactly alike
in fact i'm not sure i'd even want to
it's really showing the past through the
work we do today
can i take a look at it
oh my gosh yeah it's coming to life
right out of the right down that piece
of rock
it's kind of amazing people think rock's
dead not to me
i love that rocks live and i try to
bring them to life
well i feel so lucky to have met your
living rocks and you
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to sit down and chat with you and hear
your stories you're welcome i'm glad you
did
i had such an amazing time meeting with
the artists earlier and seeing the level
of expertise and skill that goes into
their respective crafts was such an
eye-opening experience the koala arts
and crafts mutual is such a beautiful
location and the fact that they have
been keeping the local cherokee
tradition alive for the past 75 years is
amazing i don't know about you but i
think i'm ready for my next adventure i
think i see a clue
you'll have to go underground to see
this tall beauty in person ooh tall
beauty in person i have no idea what
that means but i'm very excited you'll
have to tune in to the next episode to
find out where i'm going next
[Music]
you